[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
all right guys i think this is our spot
first things first i need two good trees
so
[Music]
well it took a while but i finally got
my japanese knife fixed
got the tip repaired
uh it's a wonderful knife
shark skin handle got it as a gift from
a friend in japan
there we go
here we go
do
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
yes
uh
oh
we gotta take a little break we got a
cold foot emergency
this one's still cold
okay
oh
my god are you feeling warm now
try putting your boot back on see if
it's warm okay okay
okay
how's that are your toes feeling warm
yeah good
[Applause]
you take it out jake
i made a bed
well i got the bed made i'm really happy
with it but i think i need to make some
adjustments to my design i'm running out
of time i need to get this done a lot
quicker
okay
guys
over here
hey
[Music]
we've got another cold foot emergency
are your feet cold
you want to see my secret to warming up
feed
tickle tickle tickle tickle tickle
tickle tickle tickle tickle you feeling
better bud yeah i think i should always
stay next to the fire
[Music]
got a lot of wood that's covered in ice
and snow so what we're going to do is
we're going to lean it
against here
and let it dry out oh it feels good to
sit down i am exhausted i was just
working as fast as i could trying to get
this done before the sunset we barely
made it looks like jacob's tuckered out
too because he's falling asleep on his
caribou hide
good for him he needs his rest let me
show you this cod i made
it's pretty cool it's just basically a
tarp that's wrapped twice around two
logs and down inside here i've got my
air mattress that log is latched to the
tree and this log is just resting on
this diagonal member because it's angled
out this way the more the log is pushed
down this way the more it's pushed out
this way and that meets resistance
against the tarp the tarp prevents that
so that's how it keeps it off the ground
all you need is to lash that and lash
that and you're done if you don't want
to use trees you can lash together two
tripods and run all three of your cross
members in between the two tripods the
nice thing about this is you don't need
a lot of paracord maybe 15 20 feet of
paracord is plenty to make all of these
lashings all right let's go check the
temperature outside
looks like it's about 17 degrees out
here
let's take this inside
see what the difference is we're gonna
put this right up here
by the bed check it out it's about 43
degrees here in the shelter so that
means it's about 26 degrees warmer in
the shelter versus outside so that's
really a big difference down here
underneath the cot it's about 38 degrees
so almost 10 degrees cooler getting
yourself off the ground even a few
inches makes a huge difference you get a
lot more of the heat from the fire and
you don't have to sleep on the ice in
the frozen ground all right i better get
some dinner ready for jacob here
a little bit of butter and garlic paste
in here we're going to try to melt this
butter without melting my tupperware
got some king crab claws there
they're all pre-cooked so all you got to
do is warm them up on the fire
salt pepper garlic powder
jake jake
jake wake up jake
jacob wake up wake up hey jake wake up
we got dinner jacob wake up
wake up jacob wake up
[Music]
oh that's good
oh yeah that that is a chunk of meat
right there
buddy you want some steak
you know it's a good steak when you
don't need to cut it up you can just
bite into it like an apple
look at that it's a huge isn't it
how big
oh they get like bigger than this i love
how the little thumb meat out of a king
crab is bigger than most lumps out of
blue crab
look at that
i know that's a big chunk of meat
you want you want a bite nope
oh so
so greasy i love it
that warm you up
yeah
[Music]
hey jacob do you want to roast
marshmallows yeah yeah all right i got a
marshmallow stick
where's your stick you got it
is that marshmallow good
yeah
you tired you want to get into bed no no
no
yeah you want a body warmer
okay these are the adhesive body warmers
they're absolutely wonderful stick these
to your undergarments when you go inside
your sleeping bag you'll be warm all
night
[Music]
get in there jake are you warm
yeah yeah there's your blankie scoot
over buddy make room for dad all right
bud you want to watch a movie together
[Music]
all right now they got jacob down i need
to get even more firewood
it's gonna take a bit
it's about a quarter 11 and jake's sound
asleep in my bed and i kind of need that
bed myself i was going to make a bed for
jake
but we kind of ran out of time so i'm
going to improvise something
[Music]
okay
i should be pretty comfy and he can't
roll out
sitting here driving my socks off i can
hear three owls having a hoot off
yeah
yeah they're going bonkers
we weren't supposed to get any snow last
night but at 7 00 a.m and uh there's a
fair amount of snow here
look at this
look at jake's bag
so
[Music]
ah warm thick slab bacon on a cold
morning it's not too bad
well it's about 9 30 in the morning and
we're just watching the sun slowly come
up we're just kind of packing up and
eating breakfast taking it easy now we
got the place cleaned up a little bit
let's get jacob out of here
all right
hold on
[Music]
oh
uh
well guys we got about an inch and a
half of snow last night and the shelter
held up really well i slept better last
night than i have in a long time it was
really comfortable on that cot
but i've got so many plans for this
shelter that i didn't get chances to do
so definitely click subscribe because
we're going to be coming back here and
working on this project some more so if
you want to see that make sure to click
subscribe and activate that notification
button thanks for watching guys hope you
enjoyed this don't forget to join us
next saturday morning if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching
[Music]